well you'll be unsurprised to hear that
the disgraced former Health secretary
Matt Hancock has disgraced himself again
as has the disgraced former Chancellor
quasi cuarte who were both caught up but
undercover sting agreeing to work for a
fake South Korean company for thousands
of pounds a day let's have a look at the
footage of the campaign group led by
donkeys
so we were we were wondering do you have
a daily rate
at the moment I do I do yes it's ten
thousand Sterling we would like to talk
about Arrangements of feeds I mean do
you have a daily rate
yeah I mean
yes I mean
um as an MP obviously I don't need to uh
create you know earn a king's Ransom but
I'm looking I would do anything less
than for about ten thousand dollars a
month
and so it went on edifyingly on MPS are
allowed to have second jobs there's no
suggestion of parliamentary rule
breaking just pure greed so should MPS
actually be paid more to stop them
behaving in this grasping way in the
first place we're joining me now is the
podcast host and author of an immigrants
love letter to the West Constantine
kissing welcome back to the program um
great to do your podcast by the way I've
had a great reaction to it good bad and
ugly which is the perfect reaction to
anything thanks for coming on um this
when you watched all this and it's in
his full gory details it was so gruesome
to watch and it was The Usual Suspects
Hancock quieting didn't surprise me at
all the quieting had very little grasp
on reality of money I said yearly rate
like he's not selling you already I did
enjoy that what I mean your takeaway
from that was that you have a belief
that MP should be paid a lot more money
I'll just say I sort of share that view
I sort of think if you paid peanuts you
get monkeys right and we're paying
peanuts and getting people who just seem
to me to be extremely low caliber
politicians and we need to somehow raise
that bar would money alone do that do
you think well the the headline to pay
them more is what people took away from
what I've been saying about this my view
is yes you pay them more but you then
also ban them from you say they're
allowed to have second jobs they're
allowed to have third jobs and fourth
jobs and fifth jobs so as long as the
incentive structure is there they're not
getting paid a huge amount for the job
that they're doing obviously compared to
the ordinary person they're they're
being paid for a chunk of money but
compared to other people operating at
the top of society I mean if you wanted
your favorite football club to be run by
someone who's very good you'd happily
pay them three four million a year right
in Singapore they pay apparently their
politicians a lot of money yeah millions
of dollars so they take your view that
you then attract the best talent your
country benefits it's actually a small
price to pay you get what you pay for
and I think with them you have to ban
the second third and fourth jobs and so
on and you have to make sure that they
put the uh stocks and shares in the
trust where they don't get uh benefits
from companies being trade in a certain
way and whatever but the bottom line is
pissed you get what you pay for and it's
interesting I mean you don't have to get
better people into Parliament right so
Singapore they get 672
000 pounds a year for an average Member
of Parliament Singapore Spain is only 49
000. Germany 108 000 United States
senators 142 000 pounds and France just
under 80 000 pounds so I guess by
comparison to most of Europe ours get
this you know in the kind of middle
range of that but Singapore dramatically
different and they believe over there
they really does attract a better
caliber and that makes perfect sense to
me I just I just think the pro one of
the biggest problems with our politics
fees is people think about tribe rather
than results and if you're tribal about
this you go well you know Hancock and
quieting of course but actually cast
your mind back to the black government
it's not like they were all squeaky
clean either we have a system in which
the incentive structure encourages
politicians not to take money from us
and to serve us we have a political
system where they take money from some
in this okay some pretend Korean company
and who are they then serving well
exactly I completely agree I want to
switch another story which I thought
would uh would probably get your
interest the Guardian newspaper owners a
guardian being the most woke newspaper
on planet Earth absolutely Beyond
reproach and they've LED Council culture
they've LED wokery they are purer than
pure whiter than white in all things
ethical and they've had an unfortunate
moment today because the Scott trust
that owns a guardian has had to issue a
public apology because it turns out the
origins of the wealth used to establish
the guardian Came From Slavery a review
found the papers founder John Edward
Taylor had links to slavery through
Partnerships in Cotton manufacturing
obviously the guardian reactions to fall
on its knees beg for mercy announce all
sorts of initiatives to prove they're
not a bunch of of racists and so on and
you'd expect that from the guardian but
a comical irony that the paper that's
driven probably more than any
publication in the world this kind of
woke mentality and been picturing
everybody else about their own
shortcomings gets caught like this this
is a very good example of this whole
thing more generally where most of these
people who claim to be kind and
compassionate they behave in the most
awful ways towards the people that they
disagree with and I think this is where
you know I'm not I don't spend a lot of
time reading the guardian I'm not going
to cancel that it's actually bad for my
mental health so I don't but what I do
think is you know everyone lives in a
glass house to some extent and I think
what I take out of this is we should all
throw stop throwing rocks around because
I I genuinely think that if you dig down
long enough every one of us has some
ancestor who did something wrong and the
less we we focus on things that happen
300 years ago and the more we come
together and try to solve the problems
of today I think the better off I just
seek this self-flagellation of the
historical stuff which current people
had nothing to do with what's the point
you know it's like this thing in San
Francisco we're looking to pay millions
and millions of dollars to every black
person who lives in San Francisco as
some kind of reparations from what
previous generations did hundreds of
years ago I don't understand how that
helps anybody no it doesn't and as you
know I talk about it in the book and the
issue of slavery more broadly I just
think we've got stuck in the past and
the way that's completely unhelpful many
of the conversations we have now in the
west are about looking Inward and going
why are we so bad why are we so wrong in
the case I'm making an immigrant's love
letter to the West is we live in one of
the most open tolerant genuinely
Progressive Societies in the history of
humanity let's appreciate that let's at
least notice that for God's sake when do
we stop celebrating our country right I
feel the same way about America new poll
came out today saying the majority of
Americans the first time I can remember
now no longer think it's the best
country in the world Americans always
used to do that right now they don't
there's a kind of again
self-flagellation about the state of the
countries now whereas America and
Britain in many ways are two of the
great countries of the world today
unquestionably and uh to me it's
mind-boggling that we're in this
position but beyond being sort of
frustrated and got all these pink haired
idiots are running around ruin whatever
to me this is a real threat peas because
if we in the west do not have the
strength of our convictions we do not
have the courage to stand up and say
you know our history is the same as the
history of every other Society we've
done good and bad but on balance we're
good we're good people we are people who
are doing good in the world
um then then other people will come and
take over you know the best works the
best people ever
in the history of this planet have all
been flawed Geniuses right I'm talking
to one and you're facing one
two prime examples constantly greatest
immigrants love that as the West really
excellent book making the points you
just make good to see you I appreciate
it thank you